So we're gonna play family feud all right everybody in as the other teams come from the showroom
They'll work their way before as we give them all time
Because we have such a captive very cool
Incredibly smart also kind of sexy
Audience all in the room. I'm looking at you Alex and as we're all sitting here
We're gonna take advantage of the fact. We all have your brains and so Rachel
Everybody say hi to Rachel
Rachel heads up our marketing team and has made everything as beautiful as it is.
So big round of applause to Rachel and her team.
Alright, Rachel is the one behind the whole rewind tour and the back of our shirts kind of have like...
Come on, anybody? Entourage fans? No? Nobody? I guess not.
If you haven't seen it, it's literally like the best show ever made.
Thank you for validating my feelings. Appreciate that.
that. So while we have everybody's minds and brains and everything else, we're
gonna just gather some feedback. So Rachel and her team, I want to give a
huge thanks for making everything so beautiful today. They have on here a survey.
Yeah, sure, big round of applause again for Rachel. Yeah, she deserves it, absolutely.
That's Lissy, part of the team, and then Selene is over here, over as well. If you guys
want to you can you can write down your answers or feel free to use what the team calls our icebox
survey thing so the icebox is just we gather any and all ideas we put them on ice until we really
want to like like bring them up and do something cool with them so you can fill out the survey if
you want to do it online or feel free to use your paper all right so each team we just have a couple
questions just looking for true and honest feedback the first question we'd love to know
know more about is tell us how best to train your team so either yourself or
others how what's the best way to train your team maybe it's something we're
doing currently hopefully it's something that we could do more of or less of or
we open all feedback you cannot hurt my feelings please you can so any and all
feedback you have including the feedback in the microphone welcome to all your
your ideas so how best can we treat your team and if you guys want to share feel
free to like raise your hand and Rachel will come around like Vanna and gather
your answers if you're brave enough to to be on the mic we got Sarah in the
back in person seminars in person seminars it's been a while yeah we had a
great event for those who were able to make it back in January January for
those who made it we we got snowed out and so many of those who braved the
weather to be there it was great but love that Sarah if we can do more of
that we certainly will so anybody else feedback on how best we can train your
team feel free I'll bring the icebox survey back up feel free to write any
ideas down if you don't want to share if you do this we have Morgan here all
right hi Morgan
Morgan. So focusing on competence, credibility, and so with every skill or like new set that you're
teaching or training, focusing on those three things. Do we have, did somebody write that down
because that was really smart? Anybody in the three C's? Or Morgan's going to write it down
for us. Competence, credibility, and compassion. I love that. Thank you, Morgan. Oh, that's great.
All right. Feel free to write your ideas down. We'll collect them at the end.
question number two if budget was not an issue how would you change your business
if budget was not an issue what what lotion would you bring in what
equipment would you bring in what how would you expand what would you do to
change your business if budget wasn't an issue I'm sitting here and I've got a
million dollars going to the best idea out there well seriously up here right
oh you just want the million dollars larger space larger space more equipment
great feedback I love that especially the more equipment part yeah if much is
not an issue guys how best would you change your business Oh miss you madam
from Quebec new beds new beds yeah for those who haven't tried it the vitality
is literally like the best tanning bed on the market right now it is absolutely
absolutely amazing so please sign up part of the whole reason for today guys
is to make sure that you guys can try new equipment and we certainly welcome
that that's where a lot of people currently are so Daniel's making sure
Rachel's not in my beautiful shot alright what number three also going to
creativity what dream product or equipment what is your dream product or
equipment it can exist or cannot exist I prefer those who don't exist so if
you're looking for a 20x bronzer with a hundred X tingle totally want to hear
about it if you're looking for a bed that gives you a massage while you lie
in it and you tan totally want to hear about it it used to exist just whatever
whatever you guys can think of no limit just creativity wins we just welcome all
thoughts and ideas all right so question one how best we train your team
question to a budget was not an issue how would you change your business and
number three is so far is what dream product or equipment is out there that
doesn't yet exist you said last time in Vancouver somebody did on the panel that
focus what you're good at so if you're good with sprays run with sprays go
mobile like expansion that way that's the the steam whistle idea right do one
thing do it really really well right so I believe in that as well I also believe
even variety, right? So
I kind of fall on both sides. Go ahead.
Tingle for sensitive skin.
Whoa. Jess, write that
down. You have a tingle for
sensitive skin? Hang on, sorry.
New Sunshine has a product.
Where's Louis? Does Voda have a product?
So Pink Crush in the Swedish Beauty
Collection is a hypoallergenic tingle
if you guys are looking for one.
Just don't put it on your face. Yes.
Don't put it on your face.
Never tingle on your face.
All right.
Cool. Anything else guys? Feel free to write your ideas down, send them in, do whatever you want to.
We welcome all feedback, anything, right? Feel free to write down the fact that you love me and
love my jacket. Totally cool. I'm going to get to that in a second. Number, and guys, we constantly
welcome feedback about this event, about our team, about our company, anything that we can do to make
ourselves better to make this more you know palatable enjoyable fun rewarding
because you guys are all taking time out of your days to be here we want to make
sure you're getting out as much what what we possibly can so please we
welcome all and all feedback we possibly can the better we are the better we be
only comes from suggestions and ideas from y'all all right so please we welcome
it all um all right let's play some feud you guys ready no you got it I'll make
make sure the buzzer thing works yes first of all do you want to do best
dress no you do that okay all done a really really good job dressing up for
these events you know this year we opted for the band t-shirts because we had the
band right just put that together but I've got to have a shout out to our
girl Megan over here. Give her a round of applause. We've got a donation. I even watched
the Barbie movie. She just found this and thought, that's an awesome 80s outfit. Another
round of applause. Thank you. Love it. Love it. Okay, so where's my friend Rachel? Come
on up. You are going to do Family Feud. And I'm going to walk around with this thing.
okay perfect okay so we need two teams to come up we need one more team on deck
please the whole team okay so one team in that corner one team in this corner
It's trivia.
All right.
View time.
Okay.
So do you guys go over the rules?
No.
You guys are a team.
So the winner buzzer, right?
See, look.
Buzzer, winner.
You guys confer amongst yourselves with a group
and pick what you think is the best answer.
Best answer stays on.
Losers go home.
So we need the other team over here in this corner.
Team over here.
Team one, team two.
And the next team, the next team on deck,
so whoever wants to come up next,
just go over to see Leanne in the waiting area there.
So we always have a consistent flow of teams coming up.
Yes, one question.
We answer one question, winner stays on,
loser goes home, all right?
Okay?
All right, we have team,
team Afterglow versus team, team Fabutan.
All right, and we have tonight,
Tonight we have Leanne and Tuck.
You guys ready?
Okay, I will start reading the question.
The first one to buzz in gets the chance to win.
Highest score stays on.
But you don't say Leanne.
You discuss as a team, okay?
So if you buzz first, correct, okay?
All right, as fast as you can go.
Question number one.
Tuck, you got this?
All right.
What are different types of tanning lotions?
Pick the number one answer.
Give me one answer between you.
the number one answer accelerator is what you guys are going with which would be an intensifier
is number two team afterglow can you pick the best one bronzer we have dha bronzer is team
number one it's a number one boom there you go there you go all right you guys stay next team
come on up great you did great you did great number two answer don't be don't be don't be
be ashamed of that so all right team afterglow versus team oh all right team spray tan right
here we go no we're in we're in for sure all right question number two aha this is meant for you
name a reason why someone might choose spray tanning aha all right number one answer let's
see what you got uh wedding which i will give a special occasion number one answer here we go
Oh, good job, nicely done, big round of applause.
Great job team Afterglow, thank you for playing.
Everybody's a winner guys, everybody's a winner.
You guys stay on.
Other answers include quick results number two,
UV free number three, and an even tan number four.
All right, we got team spray tanning versus team,
beaches?
Yeah, all right, here we go.
Okay, we have Ashley versus Emily.
We surveyed the top 50 people,
I don't even know what we did.
All right, so, name a step in prepping for a tanning session.
Oh, man, Emily, you're going to break the stage, girl.
All right.
Ooh, exfoliating.
Actually, number two answer.
Number two answer.
It is.
In spray tanning, we got to exfoliate first.
Ashley, what's the number one step in preparing for a tanning session?
Ooh, showering.
Actually, I don't have showering.
I have applying a tanning lotion as the number one answer number two was exfoliating. We're gonna stay with teeth spray tanning. He's on I
Just I go based on what people told me and how they filled out the survey whether it's the right answer or wrong
I don't know actually don't hold it to me
Hydrate was next and wear loose clothing comes in as number four. All right, you guys have three in a row so far
How you feeling two in a row? All right, take three in a row
Now I'm predicating into the future. You're gonna be three in a row. All right. All right
Alright, I'll do what I can. Again, I'm not in control, I only do, I just answer what the, yeah, you guys might lose this one. I'm just saying, okay, anyways. Alex, are you ready? Ready? Alex, what are the features of a cocoon pod?
Ooh, that was close, but Alex is the winner.
All right.
Number one answer, feel free to confer.
Team Hollywood, infrared, number one answer.
There you go.
Very strong.
Thank you, Team Spray Tanning.
Good news, you're a winner.
All right.
Team Hollywood stays on.
Dry heat sauna, number two, red light, radiance bands, massage bed,
salt therapy, and aromatherapy.
Round out those answers.
So we need another team up.
Who wants to come on up and play?
Come on, take on the challenge of beating the Hollywood crew.
All right, where are you guys from?
Town Lounge.
Town Lounge, all right.
Town Lounge versus Hollywood.
You guys ready?
Ho ho.
All right.
What are UVilux's five core values?
All right, Alex.
Ooh, customer service.
Not quite, but close.
Our values...
Oh, that was really funny.
Thanks, Alina.
It just made me feel really small.
Pardon me?
We have five core values, five ways that we kind of determine how we run in our loves, our hearts, if that means anything.
They're how we determine and make decisions on what to do with our business and our people and direction of the industry.
Customer service is not one of them.
We do that really well.
We do that better than anybody.
But it's, pardon me?
So, what do you think?
Feedback?
Judges?
Feedback.
That was an Elaine call, that was our judge right there, that was a good answer, good
answer though, good answer, good answer.
Alright team Hollywood, I'll give you one more.
We obviously don't do a good enough job talking about these things.
No we don't, alright, I try, I try, and I didn't start today with it, so that's my own
fault, that's my own fault.
Professionalism.
Professionalism, good answer, good answer, but I'm going to give you another X, but I'll
tell you the answer then you guys stay on for the next question all right so first uh our five loves
the number one answer is family which you guys are all part of right we always believe that our
family is our family and that includes our our salon family uh industry we love what we do and
we we're really passionate about giving back and making sure that our family is and the industry
is strong passion that's just smiling and enjoying this and having fun days like this right
right? So that's what we do. Loyalty comes up after that. And that's just really, you know,
good partnership between us and the salons. We really believe that that's pretty critical. It
also loyalty goes to our salon vendors and our partners. So Australian Gold and Sun Evolutions
is here. Devoted is here. Sun Inc is here, right? Hans from Miracle Line is here. So that's a big
part of that. And lastly, it's success. And we believe that if we're successful, if you're
successful we're successful so that makes up our five loves anyways family
number one answer all right I love you guys all right all right who's next no
stay on stay on we'll do the next question right okay what type of
equipment does evil excel tanning beds is great number one answer number two is
red light units number three is spray tanning and number four is infrared so
So, thank you, ladies, for playing.
Good news is you're a winner.
Lacey's got a present for you.
Yay.
All right, next team.
Who's up?
How are you guys feeling?
Where are you from?
Elysium tanning.
All right.
You guys ready?
What ingredient features are common requests for lotions?
Oh, who won that?
I missed it.
Anybody?
Oh, this side, this side.
All right, Team Hollywood won.
All right, thank you for your help, audience.
All right.
What ingredient features are common requests for lotions?
big bronzers number one answer right there big round of applause yeah you're right there like
it was like a tie like i said you were there you're there uh tattoo protection number two
yummy fragrance paraben free gluten free and hypoallergenic round out the offering round
out the list all right all right good job good job team hollywood holding strong next team come
come on up. How are you guys feeling? Feeling good? Lunch was good? All right. All right.
The question for you guys, y'all, is what are ways to break a tanning plateau?
What are ways to break up a tanning plateau? Use of a tingle is on the list, but it's number three.
Ooh. All right. Number one answer and number two answer still on the board.
Change your lotion.
Number one answer.
Oh, we have a new winner.
Here we go.
Trying different equipment, using a tingle, try products that have melanin enhancing products
or adding tan extenders to your home care system.
Round out the answer.
So great job, guys.
So where are you from?
Brantford.
Awesome.
Well, thank you for being here today.
We need a challenging team.
Anybody?
Keep in mind, guys, if you want to come up for a second time to take it on, feel free.
Oh, look at that.
I love that.
All right.
It is a lotion question, actually, Rodney.
This is perfect.
You ready?
Why use a tanning lotion?
I will take that.
I got get darker, faster, longer-lasting tan.
So, yeah, it works.
High fives.
Congratulations.
Cheaters.
That was the number one answer.
Yeah, quicker tan, hydrating to absorb UV light, and skincare round out the offering.
So, good news is everybody's a winner.
Yay!
I love this game when everybody's a winner.
All right, guys. Next team up. Come on up. Welcome back. Nice to see you guys again. All right. Who's ringing the buzzer this time? All right. You ready? Okay. What are techniques to help sell a bottle of lotion?
You.
Yep.
You can discuss.
Looking for the number one answer.
We kind of have a couple different, the answers to give you a little tips are like things we've trained in our training before, tools, ideas, thoughts, mechanisms.
Okay.
I'm not sure I have that as an answer.
I'm looking at the list and I'm going to say eh, but we'll probably come back to you.
So, all right.
Look at that.
Look at the big red X that comes across.
Don't feel bad.
I got one, too.
Okay, what are techniques that we can use to help sell a bottle of lotion?
The cost per session is the number one answer right here.
Big round of applause.
Nice, you're done.
So you guys lost, but you can come back.
All right?
So feel free to get back in line.
Cost per session, number one, the three-bottle sale.
For those of you who don't know, it's a high, medium, and low.
It's number two, provide a complimentary tile to show them the lotion benefits.
Ask open-ended questions and ask the Tanner why they've never bought a bottle of lotion before.
Round out the offering.
All right.
Hi, guys.
Welcome, welcome.
You've a luxe edition of Family Feud.
How are you guys feeling?
Good?
All right.
Who's pressing the buzzer?
All right, Cassandra, you guys ready?
Question is, what are favorite fragrances?
Ooh.
Coco Dreams, I will give you that.
It is coconut, number one answer.
So close, guys, so close.
Yeah, round of applause, round of applause.
There we go.
there we go. Sorry, guys, but feel free to come back. Fragrance-free, desert, fruity,
citrus, fresh, woody, floral, everything else kind of fits. Hello, sir. Good. All right.
We have Andy and Walter on this side. All right. Walter's more about playing against
the competition than playing against, yeah. Play the man, Walter. Play the man. Yeah.
Yeah, what question, are you ready?
All right, I feel like Walter and I are going to fight, don't you?
What question should each tanner be asked?
Walter's got it.
Light areas, good answer.
Not the number one answer, though.
It's a good answer, though, Andy, good answer, good answer.
What lotion are you using today?
Number one answer, big round of applause.
White butt, yeah, light areas, get it, get it, get it, right?
Yeah, no, sorry.
Feel free to come back, though, guys.
But good news is you get a prize.
How was your last session?
How are you doing today?
What lotion are you using on your face?
Things like that are all the other answers.
All right.
John and team, how are you guys?
We've teamed up together to take on the current champions.
All right.
How are you feeling, John?
You feeling fast?
All right.
Why?
Why should you use a facial product?
Oh, John was so quick there.
Why?
Number one answer, why should you use a facial product?
I will say, let's do that as the number one answer.
The skin is different than the rest of your body.
The skin in your face is sensitive than the rest of your body.
So great job.
Thank you so much, guys.
Well done.
Great job.
Because you wash your face more, it's out there to even out color, things like that.
Team Quebec.
back okay now anybody who has google translate this is a good time to use it okay what names
might you call a tingle lotion yeah john won it right was this side yeah what names what other
names might you call a tingle product like um hang on these guys a blush okay i don't have blush
Blush. I don't have blush.
Piquant main. Piquant main. Piquant main.
Is one of those words one of these words?
Spice?
It's amazing that they're still in our country, and I still don't understand a word.
Show? Hot? Hot? Hot? Hot?
Okay, I'll give her hot. I'll give her hot.
And I'll let her win because of the emotion and the, you know, the effusional effect.
So, yeah, hot. We'll give the winner over here.
Big round of applause for Caroline. Please stay on.
Come on. Spicy, sizzle, pepper, or warming. Round out those answers.
All right. Do we have any other contestants?
Hello, team. Where are you guys from?
Wasega Beach. Oh, we love that area. That's great. Come on up.
Who's playing the buzzer?
You got this, Diane. You feel like you're fast. You ready, Caroline?
Ready? I like this question.
Name something that might break in your salon.
Lamps. Number two answer, actually.
For the steel, the acrylic, you've got to act it out more.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Number one answer right here, acrylic.
Big round of applause.
Number two answer, though, guys, don't be ashamed of that.
That's great.
Chair, your shelf, a window is also there.
Round out their top answers.
Your will to live.
Please.
All right, all right, this is a good question.
We need a good challenger team for this one.
Come on up, come on up.
Now, something you're pressing the button?
All right, you guys ready?
Next question.
Name something gross you've found in the salon.
Caroline, you seem very excited about that one.
Not on the list.
You're allowed to...
Oh, no, it is on the list.
Actually, it made up number four.
Made up number four, but it is on the list.
it was a male specimen yes yes yes oh there's a lot of groans in the audience so yeah no no
now all the stories are coming out i can see it in the audience yeah yeah all right number one
through three are still on the list number one underwear actually no not on the list
Number one answer is P. Yes. There we go. There we go. Nice try, though. Nice try.
Vomit, sanitary pads, other things make up the list.
So you guys get a prize. Everybody's a winner.
So, OK. All right. Sounds good.
Do we have another challenger? Team Quebec is kicking butt right now.
I'm just saying we need a challenger.
Oh, my God. This is a great question. Great question.
Hey, Jacob, do you want to play?
Jacob Jacob and Brandon you guys want to play cuz I got a good question next for
you okay you guys want to play I'll come back to that question but you and
Brandon are playing all right okay go find them Jay all right question is what
clients have called tanning lotions without using the actual word other
names for tanning lotion what else have clients called tanning lotion without
They're calling it lotion.
Yeah.
Cream, number one answer.
Yeah, there we go.
Yeah.
Good job.
Potions, ointments, oils, balm all make up and round out the answer.
So, all right.
Sunless Inc., come on up.
Let's go, boys.
No, there's a question for you guys, too.
Come on.
Big round of applause for Team Sunless Inc.
Let's go.
Yeah, Brandon needs encouragement.
I'm needy.
Feed my ego.
All right.
Who's pressing the button, team?
Brandon, go.
All right.
Celebrities slash characters that have the worst spray tans.
Yes, sir.
Where do I begin?
Christina Aguilera, not on the list.
Oh, worst spray tan.
Christina's not on the list.
Celebrity with the worst spray tan.
Audience, you want to help them?
Who's that?
Donald Trump?
Trump? Not on the list, but oh my gosh, yes, yes.
Steve in the back, what do you got?
Tan Mom.
Number four, right, who else do we got?
Ross Keller, number one, there we go, yes.
Paris Hilton, Lindsay Lohan, Paul Bart, Mall Cop?
All right, I just haven't watched that movie enough, and Nicole Richie, apparently, so we're spray tans.
Thank you for playing, guys, thank you for playing, big round of applause, you guys stay on.
You love push my buttons, baby. You can push all my buttons, baby. Yes, yes.
Here we go. You ready, Morgan? Feeling fast? All right.
Reasons why someone might not use lotion.
Ah, they're stupid. I'll give you that, actually. Yeah, yeah. Number one answer.
No, it's not, but it should be.
Can you think of an answer outside of that?
Don't like the feeling. That's number five, actually, on the list.
Number one.
Allergy.
Not on the list.
So we're going to give it to number five.
So thank you for playing, guys.
Thank you.
Good round of applause.
Expensive.
Don't want to be orange.
Number one answer, though.
I tie in fine without it.
Stupid.
It still is.
Yep, absolutely.
All right, we need a challenging team.
Who's coming up?
Steve and Maureen, I'm going to call on you next.
And then we're going to get Gina up here.
Here. Team New Sunshine back up. Question is, apart from tanning lotion, besides tanning lotion,
what are some of the most popular tanning accessories? You guys. What's that? Tanning
accessories. Accessories. Goggles. Number one answer right over here. You guys are really close,
we appreciate you coming. The good news is you're still a winner. Tan fascia. You guys want to do
do one more tan fascia uh tanny the reach behind also known as your salon attendant how many people
had to put the lotion on the back like seriously still a thing and an applicator mitt some should
not yes a hundred percent all right you ready okay jersey shore cast mates that haven't made
a tanning lotion testing your jersey shore knowledge i i doesn't matter what you answer
If you hit the number one, you stay, and if you don't, you go home.
Jersey Shore characters that have not made a tanning lotion.
Ooh, Ronnie, number two, actually.
Number two answer.
Number one answer, Mike the Situation.
Mike made a lotion, didn't he?
Christopher's our in-house, like, beyond lotion expert guru.
Yeah, Devoted Creation.
Is Louis still here?
He had an extreme situation.
No, no.
Either way, you guys win.
Good job, guys.
Thank you for staying on.
Ronnie, Vinny was the number one answer.
Dina, Angelina, who I don't remember.
Sammy made up the rest.
All right, Steve and Maureen, come on up.
It's not a lotion question.
I wouldn't do that to you, Steve.
That would be mean.
That would be just really mean.
This is a really well-suited answer for you, though.
Everybody say hi to Gina.
Gina's from Sun Evolutions.
Happy to have her here today.
All right, Maureen, you're on the buzzer.
Are you feeling fast here?
You got this.
Actually, this is kind of interesting.
Who's been in the industry longer, Stephen Maureen or Hunna Lee?
Hunna Lee.
Yeah.
I think you guys have been.
I haven't.
1984.
Hunna Lee, when did you start?
82.
Honalee, when did you start in the industry?
85.
82, right here.
Everybody, Stephen Marine been here.
We've been here for 45 years, and that puts you guys at 42 years,
which is absolutely an incredible, incredible accomplishment.
So a big round of applause.
But not the question.
The question is, reason why you're in the tanning industry.
Oh, Ashley.
Ashley was faster than Marine.
What's the number one reason why you're in the tanning industry?
Yeah.
Yep. The products? Not there. Not there. But I like the answer. Thank you, Selena.
Maureen, what's the number one reason why you're in the tanning industry?
Because of me? Number one answer! Best answer of the entire day! Oh my! Champions right here!
No, that's not it. I love you, though, for that. I appreciate that. So, no. What's the
the reason why you're in the in the tanning industry better than selling insurance
would you say the people
love the people number one answer right over here right over here big round of applause
better than selling insurance fun and exciting the benefits like free tanning also a reason why
many of us are here uh and uh the moolah make up the balance we we gotta love the money too so
So stay on, Maureen, you stay on.
No, no, no, you're there.
All right, do we have a challenger to Maureen and Steve and Gina?
Anybody?
All right, Leanne's got one.
Coming on up.
Leanne, are you helping?
We're here for moral support.
Hi, Danielle, nice to see you.
Are you ready?
All right, you guys ready?
Yeah, the question is, what are various types of tanning devices and equipment?
Maureen?
Hydration station.
station go go stay in tanning beds not additional stay in tanning equipment uv equipment what what
are various types of tanning beds or equipment but stay in uv high pressure lower on the list
we got that's a number three answer uvb yeah stand up bed number two answer i'll give that
to you. All right, big round of applause. Tanning bed, a canopy, leg tanner, a foot tanner?
How did that come up there? Leg tanner's on there. Yeah, yeah. Thank you, Maureen and Steve,
for playing. Big round of applause for Maureen and Steve. For those of you who don't know,
Steve is the executive director of the JCTA, which leads and represents our industry both
nationally and as well as within Ottawa and government. So huge round of applause for
everything you guys do. Steve, thank you. Thank you so, so much. All right, we need a challenger.
We need a challenger.
Karen and Doug, come on up.
Let's go.
There's a question just for you.
Come on, Karen.
No, what?
You're not shy.
All right.
You sure?
We need a challenger.
Anybody?
Team New Sunshine, do you want to come on up?
Jess, Kaitlyn, come on up.
Team New Sunshine, come on up.
Well, if they win, then Gina can go on the other side.
They need to win first.
But you're going to have a hard time beating Daniela.
You ready?
Okay. What are ways to enhance your product knowledge?
All right, Jess, what do we got?
Webinars, number one, right there.
Big round of applause.
Stay on. Thank you so much for playing.
But good news is you're a winner.
Keep notes of which lotions you've tried.
Try all the products and learn about collections or similar group of products.
But our webinars, also found on Uvlux and Train with AG and other sites,
are super great ways to learn.
and feel free to do it in the comfort of your home
and in your underwear if you feel like.
Right, Alex?
Right.
All right.
Where's Gina?
Gina.
We have new sunshine versus sun evolutions going on right now.
All right.
For all the marbles, how are you guys feeling?
Ken?
I'm going to pick some.
All right.
I'm down to like three.
What are some ways to generate income during July, August, September, October, November?
The summer months.
What are ways to generate income during our summer, also known as our Jason months?
Offering additional services, diversity in service and retail is the number two answer.
Promotions, number three answer, actually.
So that was close.
Number one answer is EFTs and memberships, actually.
EFTs and memberships bring on a steady income and flow.
Feel free to stay on, Gina, right?
Stay on.
Bikini car wash was on the list.
Always, always a great time.
Always a great time.
All right.
Last question.
Number one reason why a client returns to your salon.
Gina's got it.
Oh, she was fast.
That's number one reason why a client returns to your salon.
But why?
But why? Need something specific.
All right, cleanliness.
Number two answer.
Number one answer still on the board and for the opportunity to steal.
I'll do people, knowledgeable staff.
Number one answer right over there.
Big round of applause.
There we go.
Loyalty programs and incentives, up-to-date equipment, and convenience round out the list.
So thank you, everybody, for participating and playing.
Great job.
Was that kind of fun?
A little bit?
All right. Good. What's next on our agenda? We're done. All right. So, hey, guys, our showroom continues and remains open.
If you guys want to stick around and try your beds and hang out. Otherwise, you know, from the bottom of our hearts, and I mean literally from the bottom of my heart,
I love the fact you guys are here. Like, it just, it, you guys are the reason why we're here, and thank you so much for being here.
so to you guys big round of applause thank you for being here to our amazing
incredible staff thank you so much for all everything all the prizes winners
are announced on the board at the front so feel free to check that on your way
out otherwise feel free to hang out and be just just chill with us otherwise
please drive safe on your way home there's freezes and dessert over here if
anybody wants one other than that yeah be well take care of yourself and be
be happy. All right. Oh, and there's free non-alcoholic beer. Help yourself. Just drive
safe. All right. Thank you so much, everybody. Love you lots. Bye for now.